racism is still the most intractable
issue in this country and we are never
going to make the progress the strides
on this issue that we ought or should if
we can't come to realize we have to have
an earnest honest transparent
conversation about what ails us and
American just isn't ready to have that
conversation we're not as americans i
should say we're not ready to have that
conversation about why race is still the
issue that it is it is the most divisive
issue in this country and on any
particular social or political issue one
sees the race davai politic ly socially
economically culturally even we're still
divided by race and so if we're not
ready to have a real earnest
conversation about I mean look at the
trouble that President Barack Obama has
gotten into on occasion by making you
know pretty simple comments as far as
I'm concerned and by simple I don't mean
to disrespect him I mean he's made
comments that are pretty you know basic
pretty normal to me at least as a black
man but he catches all sort of hell for
even injecting himself into these
concerns even though he may be asked
about it and so if we aren't prepared to
even have an honest conversation about
this issue then we're not going to work
we're never gonna make any progress on
listen I go back to my relation with
Maya Angelou for the best answer I think
to this question it is about respecting
and reveling in the humanity of every
other fellow citizen racism by any other
name or by any other definition is the
contestation of someone's humanity and
that always gets us in trouble as a
society whenever we want to shrink
rights as opposed to expanding rights
whatever we want whenever we want to
contest the humanity of any other fellow
citizen it could be ageism it could be
homophobia it could be sexism or
patriarchy it can be racism there any
number of ways in which people every day
have their humanity can
tested at the end of the day if we
cannot respect and revel in the humanity
of every fellow citizen they will never
get past these social ills their
xenophobia the races on the homophobia
that holds us back as a Great Society